not only is michael b
jordan the sexiest man alive he just
proved he's the most romantic man alive
too
i'm just genuinely excited the 34 year
old actor surprised his girlfriend
lori harvey over the weekend for
valentine's day
renting out an aquarium so they could
see some sea turtles
that alone would have been over the top
but it gets
even cuter because the black panther
star had the whole place decorated with
rose petals and
candles swoon that lavish setup was
followed by a romantic dinner for two
right there inside the aquarium prepared
by
none other than famed chef nobu i'm
super proud of that yeah super proud
yeah
yeah and when the lovebirds returned
home they were greeted by
dozens and dozens of roses candles
and a bubble bath and no no
michael wasn't done after all that
the actor gifted his 24 year old leading
lady with a certified slip
showing he purchased stock in luxury
fashion label hermes
in lori's name lori shared a peek at the
thoughtful present on
instagram writing quote the best gift
ever baby bought me stocks in hermes
i think i'm a pretty lovable guy
actually michael and laurie first
sparked romance rumors in november
before making their relationship public
on instagram
in january at the time a source told et
that they have actually been dating for
several months
but have been friends for years and a
separate source told et
that they both have the family stamp of
approval
quote lori is everything michael's
family could have hoped for him to find
she's lovely respectful and fits in
perfectly
her friends also think he's great for
her everyone around them approves of
their relationship
things have gotten serious fast but
there have been no red flags
they're both totally invested committed
and
very happy
[Music]